[Musique]
india 2015 c'est une expérience inédite
en télévision suivre en temps réel un
programme de développement durable et
faire le pari d'améliorer en cinq ans la
vie de toute une population celle de
kindia et de sa région
kindia 250000 habitants la deuxième
ville de guinée après conakry la
capitale
[Musique]
la population affronte de graves
problèmes de pollution d'accès aux soins
à l'éducation à l'eau potable
avec votre aide et en collaboration avec
des ong nous avons pu construire des
écoles rénovées des dispensaires
améliorer la production agricole
assainir la ville des actions à hauteur
d'homme en profondeur et qui commence
déjà à porter leurs fruits
nous allons aujourd'hui regarder le
chemin parcouru depuis un nom rendre
compte des progrès mais aussi des échecs
et des difficultés
[Musique]
première étape à quatre heures de route
au nord de kindia
[Musique]
la préfecture de télimélé en pleine
brousse un petit coin de far ouest
africains ou depuis un an kindia 2015
encourage la scolarisation des filles
dans les villages
[Musique]
kadiatou diallo travail pour l'unicef
elle a 43 ans elle est guinéenne et
sillonne les pistes pour assurer la
bonne marche du projet
pour voir un peu comment les choses ont
évolué pourtant au niveau de l'école au
niveau des enseignants au niveau des
enfants mais aussi au niveau de la
communauté
il faut s'assurer tout ce qu'on a
commencé est en train de bien évolué et
que
tous les acteurs qui sont impliqués dans
le projet chacun en train de jouer
correctement sa partition
kadiatou commence sa tournée par l'école
de bas p
elle est accueillie par le nouveau
directeur
salaire et fois que j'ai quitté vous
étiez
l'actrice n'était pas fini oui mais là
c'est la même tueur aussi n'était pas
complètement achevé merci maintenant
c'est fini et nous sommes vous n'êtes
pas depuis quand je suis là depuis
maintenant près de deux semaines m
ça oui c'est pour le dernier arrivage
et là on a fait une distribution encore
des cahiers de l'unicef que vous voyez
comme ça voilà et salah c'est que nous
venons de recevoir la seulement dans la
rue les yeah on n'a pas voulu mentionner
sert d'abord dans ce que nous avons
relayé n'a pas été mentionnée la loi ces
trois numéros des désignations 2,7 en
quand on devient sur le terrain on
vérifie que toutes les ressources
qu'elles soient matérielles ou autres
qu'on a un vrai pour les communautés
sont arrivés à destination parce que
nous on ne dépose pas directement ici
les choses on les dépose au niveau de la
direction préfectorale de l'éducation
avant que ne commence un suivi sérieux
je ne sais pas qui le voulaient mais
pour trouver le matériel qu'on m'a
donnée pour les écoles on le retrouvait
au marché donc du coup on a renforcé le
suivi et je crois que depuis que les
gens savent que nous faisons ça ça
beaucoup bu chez des sujets ne pratique
on ne rencontre plus l'an dernier à bas
pays les enfants étudiés ici dans cette
petite bicoque en banco de la bouse de
vache sécher
l'institutrice kenda diallo se débattait
avec un mobilier hors d'âge est hors
d'usagé des classes surchargées avec un
lit pour 10 élèves aujourd'hui kenda
s'occupe toujours des enfants du cp
entrée en cours allaient pas aussi une
cinquantaine d'élèves de 5 à 8 ans
ce matin c'est le cours de français
découverte pour les plus petits qui
devront faire toute leur scolarité dans
cette langue très mal maîtrisée en
brousse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
s'il te plaît respondi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on est madame la barre adam permettez
moi de prendre in ferait maintenant
madame dupont tu prends la craie et
qu'est ce qu'on dit d'abord
[Musique]
qu'est ce qu'on dit
le projet qui nous tient à 2015 a déjà
permis la construction de six nouvelles
écoles soit 18 classes entièrement
équipée avec le matériel scolaire pour
accueillir 3 126 enfants auparavant
privés d'école résultat le taux de
scolarisation est passé de 38 à 45 % en
deux ans pas mal pour un début
mais il reste des difficultés à
surmonter
ici c'est un jeu wii c est par là c'est
le cp et ce1 sur la baie james ici c'est
une deuxième salle
oui qui n'est pas d'abord utilisé parce
qu'à part une troisième enseigne mais
nous obliger les deux niveaux là bas et
l'équipe et comment les autres comme les
autres madame
et pourquoi vous êtes deux ans ayant
pour trois salles de classe la réponse à
cette question doit être répondu par
l'autorité si cagliari
[Musique]
d école toute neuve mais des salles
vides faute de profs
[Musique]
une situation absurde à laquelle
kadiatou doit faire face pour atteindre
l'objectif de scolariser 80% des enfants
d'ici 2015
[Musique]
l'affectation des enseignants c'est la
responsabilité de l'état guinéen
kadiatou diallo et ses collègues de
l'unicef sont venus réclamer des moyens
au ministre de l'éducation des profs
pour les nouvelles écoles
[Musique]
merci oui ça va aller mal bien oui voilà
comme ça ça va ça marche comme vous le
savez on a commencé le projet de l'année
dernière le projet dénommé projet
d'accélération de l'éducation des filles
mais on trouve plus d'enseignants on est
à la limite de ce que nous pouvons faire
les bâtiments les beaux bâtiments sont
là mais hélas pas d'enseignant donc je
viens accompagné de représentants pour
voir qu'est ce que vous pouvez faire
pour nous aider pour ça avant la rentrée
prochaine
le concours est fait les résultats sont
là avant la rentrée prochaine tous ceux
qui en ont besoin en matière enseignants
va être complètement comblé est ce que
vous savez qu'à qu'on a cuit il y à une
pléthore de plus de 1000 enseignante qui
fournit près les femmes
le prétexte est simple nous marier ici
je dois approché mon enfant mal et mes
enfants sont là
voilà la situation c'est sûr des
promeneurs qui va être fait cela ajouté
à tout ce que nous avons essayé la rue
fusey de passe ne peut pas les fusions
en coupe les salaires a sorti la
fonction publique la première que j'ai
pris fonction nous avons radiés ou de
nos fichiers 515 enseignants en
situation d'abandon de poste
ils sont payés par la fonction publique
comme étant des enseignants considèrent
dans le fichier enseignants mais ils
servent ailleurs où ils ont même quitté
le pays nous n'allons pas résoudre de
façon systématique tous les preuves que
nous avons trouvé ce qu'est une évidence
c'est une évidence ne l'ont pas reçu de
tous les plans de façon systématique
mais nous allons faire un effort pour
qu'en 2015
notez qu elle se porte mieux vous
connaître encore supporter mais nous
ferons un effort pour que d'ici 2015
était contenue et que vraiment tous les
enfants en tout cas un âge d'étudier le
maximum puissent avoir accès à l'école
l'accès aux positions de l'énergie aux
accompagnants
[Musique]
attirer et maintenir les enseignants
dans ces coins perdus reste un défi
[Musique]
d'ailleurs kendall l'institutrice du
village de bp envisagent de partir cette
femme de la ville a de plus en plus de
mal à supporter la vie en brousse
à commencer par la case qui fait office
de logements de fonction ce faire il n'y
a pas de fenêtre
non mais c'est quoi ça fait se détacher
sa tombe
et vous avez vu c'est comme ça que je
fais c'est le plafond donné ça mais ça
se détache pendant la nuit pendant que
tu es coucher oui pendant que je dors
c'est pour cela que j'ai mis ce drame tu
vois ces communautés tu peux pas louer
une maison qui n'a pas un bâtiment avec
des chambres où tu peux loin donc ce
sont eux qui te donne une case et une
case comme celle-là ce qu'elle me disait
c'est que pendant la saison des plus si
ça continue comme ça pendant la saison
des coûts nous va couler de danut coman
gelé des commandes valident pas voir
jusqu'où il pourra tenir si la limite
même s'il faut utiliser la salle de
classe parce qu'elle n'aurait par le
show pendant ghosn va franchement ici la
qualité de vie est misérable
il faut du courage
oui je mène une vie dure si tu rates le
marché du jeudi
tu dois attendre la semaine d'après pour
faire tes courses en plus le marché trop
cher on y achète trois petits poissons
fumés pour 5000 francs
allez on est
les fins de mois sont difficiles ici tu
peux chercher pendant deux heures du
réseau pour ton téléphone sans réussir
pas de radio pas de télé rôle où on est
on est dans un trou on regrette tous les
jours
[Musique]
m
dans la région sont construites les
écoles de kindia 2015 il manque 200
instituteurs au niveau national dans les
zones rurales
c'est près de 3000
[Musique]
ouais
oh
en 2011 nous avions découvert le site de
en peau ni une mangrove dévasté par la
coupe de bois
[Musique]
un mal nécessaire pour sénégalais le
producteur de sel qui n'avait pas
d'autre option que de travailler avec le
feu ils se tuent à la tâche
asphyxiés par les vapeurs toxiques mais
il fallait bien faire bouillir l'eau
salée pour obtenir quelques sacs de sel
et attention il en train de jouer avec
la saumure sénégalais c'est aujourd'hui
converti à la production de sel sur
bâche plastique une technique mise au
point par l'omg universel un seul
salaire écologique ni bois ni feu
sénégalais complice sa révolution
agricole mois la petite faut qu'on se
dépêche et à la télé
si tu ne tiens pas la bâche assez fort
bah tu ne pourras pas bien remuer et le
sel ne se décollera pas
money ball hamas à ma vie a complètement
changé
je ne souffrais la boue ou fat eden
avant mon corps me faisait mal par c'est
fini tout ça moi à l'époque je devais
acheter plein de médicaments avant la
saison ça me coûtait très cher mais
aujourd'hui je n'achète plus rien je ne
prends plus de compris parce que mon
travail ne me fait plus souffrir nous
fallait cette année abbas
j'ai envie de causer de 30 vaches et les
affres et andy comme ça je pourrais
produire 30 tonnes de serre
ça représente cinq fois plus de sel
qu'avant les bâches non ma disposer mon
ambition
et puis nous notons je suis venu avec
cette décision ferme dès 6 ans forme
j'ai aussi décidé de conserver le sel
que je produis en forêt à la dapa pas
saurait non fort parce que si tu produis
30 tonnes inara nos forêts je tue le
conserve et que tu le revends ribes
alors tu peux construire une maison il
normal où tu peux acheter une voiture
je vais donc stocker moncel pendant
trois ans trois ans au total
ensuite je le revendrai à ce moment là
je pourrai prendre ma retraite
je voulais c'est fait avec de l'eau
propre noter la la technique du sel
solaire a été mise en place sur 85 sites
en guinée où travaillent plus de 1300
producteurs de sel avec les familles ça
fait potentiellement très de dix mille
personnes dont la vie a changé grâce aux
bâches plastiques et aujourd'hui sur ces
sites
la mangrove commencent à repousser
[Musique]
à
pour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et ça lui
[Musique]
et cette voiture est un peu trop chargée
non avec l'argent du sel sénégalais a pu
réaliser son rêve et faire construire
une maison en dur avec un toit en tôle
venir à lille grâce à mon travail je
suis capable de bien nourrir ma famille
allez vous faudra même si je devais
mourir aujourd'hui je n'aurais aucun
regret tout ce que je possède
aujourd'hui c'est le prix de mon travail
parce que j'ai passé 40 ans de ma vie
sans rien construire auparavant c'est
grâce à la production de sel que je suis
enfin parvenu désormais au village
sénégalais est accueilli avec respect et
admiration
y compris par son frère aîné le chef de
la famille je prie allah pour qu'il est
sénégalais a avancé qu'il lui procure
beaucoup de chance qu'ils réussissent
encore plus et qu'il peut céder encore
mieux sa famille nous sommes rassemblés
en famille aujourd'hui pour te dire que
tout ce que tu fais est un exemple pour
les autres c'est un exemple pour les
autres
celui qui tend vie est là qu à faire
comme toi
celui qui est jaloux là qu'a faire comme
toi can you can't amtin quand j'ai
commencé
si j'avais abandonné les gens se
seraient moqués de moi may be années
mais aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup de
personnes viennent me voir qu'ils
étaient les fils un pour me demander de
les aider à avoir débat
ab-f il faut toujours être courageux
[Musique]
ce soir c'est signer broussailles
anthony l'équipe de tournage va projeter
le premier volet de la série kindia 2015
réalisé il ya un nom honni
on vous présentait un film auquel vous
avez participé activement tout le
village
et puis certains d'entre vous de façon
un petit peu plus apporte comme
sénégalais sa famille donc avec beaucoup
de plaisir qu'on vient nous présenter ça
parce qu'on tient absolument montrer
qu'on fait écouter les images qu'on
prend pour que la confiance qui est déjà
bien installée ici perdure voilà donc
c'est des choses qui sont dans votre
région que vous allez découvrir aussi
sans doute
eh bien j'espère que vous allez aimer
voilà merci chaque année à la saison
sèche
il arrive sur la zone éparpillés par
petits groupes
loin de tous les campements de fortune
même la maille et c'est un maillet elle
mange une mangue
[Musique]
j'ai beaucoup pleuré tout à l'heure
surtout quand j'ai revu mes conditions
de travail de sel avant les larmes me
sont montées aux yeux j'ai vu la
souffrance dans laquelle j'étais
[Musique]
dieu merci aujourd'hui j'ai un travail
beaucoup moins pénible je ne suis plus
obligé de faire la cuisson la nuit je
peux rentrer et me reposer chez moi je
souhaite à tous les producteurs de sel
[Musique]
en guinée le taux de mortalité des
enfants de moins de cinq ans et 54 fois
plus élevé qu'en europe une femme
guinéenne à 100 fois plus de risques de
décéder au cours de son accouchement
qu'une femme européenne
[Musique]
s'il est là ce
le docteur claude moncorgé est de retour
en guinée
cet ancien président de médecins du
monde dirige le palms l'organisation
panafricaine de lutte pour la santé lo
ng intervient kindia pour renforcer le
système de soin auprès des enfants et
des femmes enceintes
l'an dernier le centre de santé du
quartier de wendy était dans un état de
délabrement avancé le dr diallo exerçait
comme ils pouvaient dans des conditions
très rudimentaire c'est très vétuste
très métis ce microscope l'aï date de
quand ça sort là
un an plus tard le dispensaire a été
entièrement réhabilitée grâce à l'équipe
du docteur moncorgé il tourne à plein
régime
ça très plaisir de revenir c'est un
trait de wendy écoutent oui elles ont
avancé quand même bonjour
bonjour bonjour ça va aussi
[Musique]
nous avons à le laboratoire bon ici
c'est le laboratoire qui a réhabilité
avec un équipement adéquat comme promis
par parce que ça fait plaisir de voir ce
qui est avancé va quand on voit la
paillasse l'année dernière un microscope
tout neuf avec ses larmes
un stérilisateur une centrifugeuse rien
ne manque
le personnel du centre peut enfin
soigner décemment des patients
[Musique]
bonjour je sais à la salle
d'accouchement très bien notamment
réhabilité avec le carrelage du sol
guide tous vos missions que ça change et
alice maintenant on a des chocs et
intérêts alizée avec un pass est née
nouveaux équipements comme nine donc en
fait il ya la table oui et il ya le lit
pour le repos après le repos après
l'accouchement
en règle générale quand tout se passe
bien combien de temps vous gardez là la
maman se poser là on a pas de zone 1h 2h
bon donc c'est mieux que l'année
dernière et très éloquente
depuis un an grâce à kindia 2015 la
palce à réhabiliter et équiper six
centres de santé trois d'entre eux
fonctionnent même à l'énergie solaire
pour éviter les accouchements à la
bougie l'année dernière nous avions
assisté ici à la naissance d'une petite
fille dans des conditions précaires
un an plus tard la petite fête matin est
suivie au centre s'apprête à celle
annuel
posez la sur la table c'est fatoumata sy
de la n 9 ans qui est né à thème au
simple de santé ici avec la matrone
depuis dix mois
ça m'a renvoyé pour ce sont le suivi
médical donc leur fait il est
complètement vaccinés et donc on voit
que la maman est un ciel et le suit bien
son enfant est vraiment essayé nous
modèle qu'il faut apprécier parce
qu'elle suivait cruellement de l'état de
l'enfant
l'enfant à huis clos bessat 70 grammes
et un revers contre les attaques elle se
fait descendre seul à la phase 5 12 2 5
m
honda 10 - c'est bon avec son goût cm
[Musique]
comment va-t-elle elle a un petit
problème d'alimentation
parce que sa mère la lettre mais elle ne
lui donne rien tôt maintenant à son âge
elle peut manger des bananes de la purée
de pommes de terre ou du bouillon ou là
sur mes sentiments
c'est un duel à mater ces mots font des
bâtiments dans ce repas il faut
absolument éviter ce qui est amer has
been hayate montmagny je suis plutôt
content parce que finalement ce qui
avait été projeté a été fait donc tout
ça va contribuer un probablement inciter
les gens
plus consultés ce qui est un des
objectifs quand même pour nous puisque
je répète moins de la moitié des femmes
enceintes
ils vont consulter leurs centres de
santé au cours de leur grossesse donc
pour améliorer leur santé et diminuer la
mortalité infantile et maternelle c'est
bien à ce stade là qu'il faut les
inciter à venir consulter
et puis si elle arrive dans le centre de
santé où il ya des meilleures conditions
d'accueil et des meilleures prestations
et bien une partie du travail aura été
fait avec des objectifs l'espère seront
attache cassia un quartier populaire de
kindia
[Musique]
je
chris young a marre à shediac et la
patronne du dispensaire local également
réhabilité grâce à kindia 2015 ici tout
le monde l'appelle titille les habitants
la connaissent bien et apprécie les
services de cet ancien sage femme dans
le quartier c'est un peu la maman de
tout le monde affiche et où sont les
couches
tu as des couches propres avec toi et
ses pieds sont très froids il ne faut
pas que ses pieds soit froid comme ça
mon et la remontée avec ce temps il vaut
mieux éviter de l'exposer à la fraîcheur
d'obama
[Musique]
l'une des missions de titi camara
empêcher la transmission du sida de la
mère à l'enfant
ayed le premier enfant ce qui amène moi
ton enfant il faut que je le consulte
parce qu'il est malade là entre brigue
et ma famille il a quel âge un mois am -
les eaux sans traitement un bébé attrape
le virus de sa maman séropositive dans
40 % des cas
mais si la mère et l'enfant bénéficie de
médicaments distribués gratuitement ici
le risque de transmission est quasiment
nul
cette jeune mère infectée par le virus a
ainsi pu éviter à son fils d'être à son
tour contaminer
il ne faut pas porter de la caméra il ne
faut pas fumer ton visage et tu sera
complètement anonyme
donc tu peux répondre aux questions sans
aucun tabou
tu comprends oui c'est mon mari qui m'a
transmis le vih
sait-on mariquita contaminés oui le
monde est en colère contre lui ce n'est
pas bien ce qu'il a fait il savait qu'il
était contaminé
ça m'a beaucoup choqué si j'avais su
avant j'aurais demandé le divorce
maintenant c'est trop tard
je suis condamné à rester avec lui et
attendre la volonté de dieu tu as eu
peur pour ton info oui j'ai eu peur
qu'il est le vih aussi tu vois je
t'avais dit qu'entre non ce médicament
koffi serait épargnée par la maladie
l'idée c'est bien d'intégrer le
dépistage du vih des femmes enceintes à
l'ensemble du suivi de grossesse très
important et ensuite de permettre à ces
femmes enceintes séropositives de
recevoir les bons médicaments pour
annuler la transmission à l'enfant
et tout ça est faisable
tout ça est faisable est d'importance et
que les femmes puissent dans de bonnes
conditions prendre des traitements qui
sont quand même de plus en plus
disponibles de plus en plus facile à
prendre
avant c'était 15 ou 20 gélules par jour
aujourd'hui c'est un comprimé une fois
par jour
la femme peut allaiter normalement son
enfant est l'objectif de diminuer
drastiquement la transmission mère
enfant du vih à l'orée 2015
on sera sera atteindre par ce type de
programme
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
titi camara habite le quartier où il a
grandi celui du grand marché central de
kindia
[Applaudissements]
le coeur de la ville ici on trouve de
tout sept jours sur sept
[Applaudissements]
c'est combien trente mille fait le moins
25000 rajoute moi un petit cadeau alors
et
titi su bien seul aux besoins de sa
famille depuis la mort de son mari il ya
deux ans elle élève quatre filles qui
font toutes les études le seul moyen
d'échapper au destin ordinaire des
femmes en guinée car elles font des
études de front toutes des études est
bon c'est des filles qui font la fierté
de la famille parce que depuis qu'elles
sont rentrés à l'école depuis abba âgées
depuis la maternelle jusqu'à ce qu'elles
ont terminé
vraiment il n'y a pas eu de problème à
leur niveau au point de vue études et au
point de lui ai dit qu'à sion je suis
très fier de mes enfants très fier parce
que la condition des femmes en guinée
est très difficile les femmes guinéennes
vivent très difficilement
celles qui ne sont pas scolarisés elles
vont chercher du bois tel qu'ils
viennent au marché elles vont faire à
manger
le monsieur lille est à la maison il
fait le grand pas trop et c'est la femme
qui fait tout pour certaines par tout le
monde et pour certains pensent que la
femme elle est faite pour la maison elle
est faite ou travailler elle est faite
pour chercher de quoi faire vivre la
famille bon avec une indication à la
sensibilisation on peut les amener à
comprendre que la femme est égal à lons
le lendemain retour au centre de santé
de cassia titi organise une réunion
publique d'information sur le sida à
destination des femmes du quartier
venez vous asseoir ici une première sur
un sujet qui véhiculent encore beaucoup
d'ignorance et de peur bonjour tout le
monde
comment ça va il est allé je m'appelle
jacques riou christiane camara mais mais
titi c'est plus facile à dire
donc allez donc mon nom est docteur titi
docteur petit arabe appelle ton petit
défi donc je suis là tant d'outils de
tout le monde ici si tu nettoies ta
maison 20 mai que ton voisin mais ces
déchets vers chez toi ron et que les
moustiques viennent avec le virus
comment on fait donc en fait pour toi
une piqûre de moustique peut transmettre
le vih
oui une piqûre peut donner le sida votre
formation vous devez savoir chelsea là
ne se transmet pas par les moustiques
vous savez pourquoi parce que le ventre
d'un moustique est chaud et que le sida
ne supporte pas la chaleur et donc les
moustiques ne transmettent pas le vih
madame je voudrais savoir une épouse et
contaminé parmi les trois co épouse
parce que le mari tourne entre ces trois
femmes là si une des épouses et
contaminés et que les deux autres ne le
savent pas comment ça se passe face à
lui s'il y a trois femmes dans le même
foyer et que le mari fait la roule entre
les trois épouses et bien les trois
femmes seront contaminés un film animé
une des femmes est contaminée elle doit
le dire et surtout pas le cacher le mari
doit savoir ne pas contaminer ses autres
femmes
on voit l'amour je vous remercie et je
suis vraiment très content je confie à
nous et c'est quelque chose ne va pas il
ne faut pas hésiter à nous le dire
wallis vous pouvez m'appeler pour quoi
que ce soit je suis à votre entière
disposition pour l'année qui arrive le
projet kindia 2015 va permettre de
réhabiliter et d'équiper six centres de
santé supplémentaires et de dispenser
des formations médicales et sociales à
300 personnes soit un meilleur accès à
la santé pour deux cent mille habitants
la quasi totalité des femmes en âge de
procréer et enfants en bas âge de kindia
[Applaudissements]
oh
on
non
[Musique]
à
oui
[Musique]
m
oh
[Musique]
retour à l'école de ba paix dans la
région 7% seulement des filles achève
l'école primaire
ce sont les pires chiffres de guinée
alors kindia 2015 se bat pour leur
offrir les mêmes chances que les garçons
et parvenir d'ici deux ans à la parité
en matière d'éducation
l'année dernière nous avions rencontré
bilguissa qui triplait son cp faute
d'enseignants pour assurer la classe
supérieure
découragé bilguissa pont s'est même
arrêté définitivement l'école
aujourd'hui bilguissa à 11 ans elle a
enfin été admise au ce1 puisqu'il ya
désormais un professeur
c'est ça incisez pelisse et verbales
verbaux plus des compléments kadiatou
pâle à fanta et marine
à la récréation
mes fils ont regroupé là bas nous on
reste ici nous sommes meilleurs qu'elle
à l'école c'est pas vrai il ne révise
pas une font rien ils n'ont pas la
cuisine à faire comme nous mais qui joue
jusqu'à la tombée de la nuit quand ils
rentrent nous avons déjà tout préparé
neymar eux il ne faut pas manger non
c'est pas vrai
[Applaudissements]
alors
c'est du riz ont chassé douloureux quand
je pile mais quand je m'arrête je n'ai
plus mal ah oui tu es ma sont abîmés on
est presque arrivé comment ça se passe
l'école cette année bilguissa les choses
ont changé et et nous ne manquons de
rien allah est fausse nous avons de bons
professeurs et du matériel de travail
je pense réussir à rattraper son retard
[Musique]
nouveau prêté gsm ou à nommer ou
peut-être que je vais réussir nouvelle
et je suis dans une course contre la
montre
au lieu de me tu vas y arriver et vous
comment vous voyez l'avenir dont je
souffre mais si dieu le veut
ça va changer un jour je garde espoir
qu'un jour mes enfants réussissent ce
qui m'inquiète c'est ma santé
car je travaille tout depuis que j'ai
perdu mon premier mari je suis seul pour
tout faire un disque nouveau mari ne me
donne presque rien parce que ce ne sont
pas ses enfants
c'est pourquoi je me bats pour mes
enfants houdaille mais à la balle si
j'abandonne les gens elles n'auront plus
rien à manger quand l'état d'alabama vie
est dure à la commissione oui je dois
être liés dur pour diminuer les
souffrances de ma maman
temps plein de méthane peut naître
son iphone bel âge et qu'ils me love
stories aux amas d'algues vertes
il a mis ses murs aux frissons
atteindrez fameux voyage on dirait des
nids d'oiseaux ramé sort parmi les
ouvrages mais sourit 3 mai berceau des
comptages acipa fille mia va partir aux
soins ias boe s'est fait un nom
yabo l'étonné maison ja bodineau roland
va s'y passer
[Musique]
ici la vie est trop dure
c'est difficile
y en a qui on souffre tous les jours
hi media on étudie pour pouvoir quitter
ce village et elle en tout et vaut
environ
on va être dans une eau forte ça y est
il y a tout ce qu'il faut banon il ya
des motos des vélos et des voitures il
ya aussi des bateaux pour notre
résidence à la base on ne marche pas on
prend les transports
[Musique]
le bois en guinée est indispensable au
quotidien
la très grande majorité des guinéens n'a
accès ni au gaz ni à l'électricité
c'est l'unique source d'énergie deux
fois par mois fait aussi la part avec
ses enfants pour l'accorder
d'ailleurs on ne trouve plus de bois la
forêt très loin on dirait le seul moyen
c'est de connaître quelqu'un qui vient
de défricher son champ droit
en plus c'est pénible je peux te couper
bon mazel je peux être mordu par un
serpent du maine
il ya des morceaux de bois qui peuvent
blesser les enfants pinceau en main
c'est trop de difficultés
fatou et les siens doivent parcourir
plusieurs kilomètres de marche pour
ramener les fagots en afrique de l'ouest
la guinée bénéficie d'un environnement
exceptionnel
plus du quart du pays est recouvert de
forêts mais ce couvert végétal est en
danger en vingt ans la guinée a déjà
perdu 10% de ses forêts chaque année 36
mille hectares sont coupées brûlées et
ne repousse pas une surface comparable à
50000 terrain de football
la cuisine à la guinéenne ça se prépare
comme ça sur le trois pierres c'est la
méthode traditionnelle
c'est tout simple mais le 3 pierre a
beaucoup de défauts peu isolé il
consomme trop de bois il expose les
femmes et leurs enfants à une chaleur
excessive et à des fumées toxiques selon
l'organisation mondiale de la santé des
fumées domestique provoque chaque année
deux millions de décès dans le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
heureusement aujourd'hui fatou utilise
un nouvel appareil le cuiseur à bois
économe il s'agit d'un four en taule
parfaitement isolé basique mais
révolutionnaire
j'utilise deux fois moins de bois avec
le cuiseur et colin guillard camaro les
sauver donc le cuiseur est bien mieux
que le foyer trois pierres bientôt je
cuisinerai tout avec le cuiseur à bois
et malema s'est vraiment le plus
rentable
romain lala hakim noury beau en plus le
3 pierre dégage beaucoup de fumée avec
l'épisode tu peux même t'habiller en
blanc tu ne seras pas sali tu économises
aussi de l'argent avec le foyer
traditionnel un fagot de bois dur à
peine une semaine alors qu'il dure deux
semaines avec le freezer maintenant
quand il pleut je peux faire la cuisine
à l'intérieur de ma maison est
aujourd'hui de plus en plus de femmes
qui lisent un cuiseur à bois
c'est important pour notre santé et on
ne rigole pas avec ça
[Musique]
jeanne métayer française c'est une
spécialiste des énergies renouvelables
elle est venue mesurer les effets du
cuiseur sur l'environnement local
j'ai fait des études d'ingénieur en
énergie environnement
mais moi ce qui m'intéressait depuis le
début c'était l'énergie mais dans les
pays les plus pauvres
voilà où le manque est vraiment criant
c'est pour ça que j'ai choisi de
m'engager dans cette voie c'est le
manière de faire un peu le lien entre
ici le sud
et puis le nord où on n'a pas les mêmes
besoins pas les mêmes réalités
mais voilà il ya des liens quand même il
ya des mécanismes qui existent pour
aider
donc moi c'est ça qui m'a attiré en plus
du côté aventure découverte
bon j'ai pas que c'est indispensable
mais en tout cas je sens que mon travail
va servir à quelque chose quoi
jolie culbute et non moi j'ai pas votre
technique alors ça tombe en plus
d'épargné la santé et la forêt le
cuiseur dope l'économie locale un cercle
vertueux
tout est envoyé sur place
en tout cas à partir des soldes jusqu'au
cuiseur fini ça c'est tout fait ici et
ça notre fierté parce que ça a été
vraiment difficile à mettre en place
voilà il ya eu des périodes un peu
creuse des parades plus chargé
et puis bon il faut savoir qu'avec une
vieille il ya des difficultés le courant
l'électricité
très aléatoire et
en tout cas ils ont les ont travaillé
d'arrache-pied pour les cuiseurs et ils
ont un grand savoir faire ici un peu
mauvaise il invente même leur routine il
trouve les innovations tout seul c'est
des vrais professionnels quoi il n'y a
aucune raison de le faire en france
donc moi je suis sûr que ça va être un
grand succès
3300 cuiseur ont déjà été produits et
vendus à kindia
de quoi faire vivre une vingtaine de
forgeant un cuiseur à bois made in
guinée coûte une quinzaine d'euros à
fabriquer pour faciliter sa diffusion et
les vendus au public à seulement 7 euros
moitié prix les différences est
subventionné par kindia 2015 1955 basse
et le mil neuf cent cinquante cinquième
cuiseur produits et cas à kindia donc
c'est un numéro de série 1 qui pour la
traçabilité du cuiseur on sait qu'elles
puisent eure a été vendue quant à qui et
où
comme ça on peut le retrouver et un
poids aussi prouver qu'il est bien en
utilisation
pour l'avenir le projet kindia 2015 va
donc continuer à subventionner le prix
du cuiseur pour faciliter sa diffusion
et parvenir ainsi à 9000 cuiseur
fabriqués et vendus à l'horizon 2015
soit plus de 15 mille trois cents tonnes
de bois guinéen est pas renier chaque
année l'équivalent de 500 semi remorque
[Musique]
et
puis
non
[Musique]
ans
l'école primaire du village de mme abbey
a été la première à sortir de terre
il y a tout juste un an trois classes et
trois enseignants ici pour l'instant le
projet tient toutes ses promesses
m bangoura le prof de cm2 nom revient
pas actuellement depuis cette année vous
si vous vérifiez le cahier de présence
zhao qu'une absence de prise de
conscience des parents eux mêmes se
motiver parce que si c'était avant la
costume cette école alors là c'est le
moment des de la coupe de la coupe du
bois les défis chemin les grandes
beaucoup de grains dans les partys
là-bas pour au moins deux mois il
devient pour moi ici mon chien donc
actuellement neurologue depuis
l'ouverture je vous dis je n'ai
enregistré aucune absence nous motiver
c'est ça un courage même laser quand tu
trouve toute sa classe tous les jours
arrête ça te met à l'aise
le professeur est à l'aise
les cm2 eu un peu plus stressé dans
trois mois ils vont passer l'examen
d'entrée au collège l'équivalent de
l'ancien certificat d'études françaises
du coup ils viennent réviser même les
jours de repos dimanche et jeudi en
guinée est ce que les filles viennent au
point que les garçons l'image est violée
toutes les filières et elle même peur
elle promet de cette année de faire du
bateau de locaux avant à 1
france 3 à 4 années et pas des planètes
à transit et 20 minutes
l'an dernier m bangoura avait réussi un
exploit faire entrer des gamins du
village au collège une première ici
depuis dix ans au moins l'année dernière
les enfants n'avaient pas de dotation la
grille du baril de tout cela il venait y
en a même qui n'avait pas déclaré en
fait et vous avez fait 50% avec wii
cette année nous remontons encore le
défi vous avez zorro 02 96 pour ça bravo
oui 35 ceci en commun des documents vous
êtes optimiste
cette fois-ci voiliers et jules à mesure
que j'explique ouvrir à mesure ils
travaillent dans les villes
ça devient plus facile pour moi dire 30
dans le new delhi et donc nous faire
avoir
la nouvelle rio ils ont serré la visite
du gouverneur pour réussir son pari
l'enseignant compte notamment sur sept
élèves
uribe l'as bari c'est sa deuxième
tentative l examen après son échec de
l'année dernière l'examen l'année
dernière n'avait pas venu ici je vois
cette année depuis qu'il ya une la côte
issus de cette école et la paire courage
avant c'était travaux de la famille
qu'il a merdé est devenu en retard le
soir arrivé quelques fois la maman était
riche en sel qui préparait donc ça fait
c'étaient des difficultés nommé cette
année sa maman la décharge et d'ups à
l'écriture c'est ce qui manque
maintenant il écrit un peu mal mais
c'est que comme elle l'a promis
elle m'a dit qu'elle va réussir je sais
qu'ils résident
[Musique]
vous devinez laquelle
pas de retard
je souhaite devenir secrétaire
secrétaire dans les bureaux en ville en
étant secrétaire je croiserai des
dirigeants et des gens importants tous
les jours comme de ta cette année je
pense réussir
waouh je redouble d'efforts communs
ronaldo j'aide ma mère mais surtout je
révise le gang congolais quand je
reviens de l'école jean c'est le net et
je travaille chez les autos que vous
allez je ne pense pas qu'une veillée qui
joue au t2 10 le coach le tennis lessing
6 août et de 12,1 je veux courir et lay
canada
je n'hésiterai pas à vendre mais bien
compris mes meubles mais je veux que ma
fille étudie quand j'ai appris son échec
à l'examen l'année dernière
je n'ai pas mangé et j'ai passé mon
temps à pleurer et qu'elle a un moment
donné j'ai voulu la retirer de l'école
son frère à sa place
[Musique]
les enseignants ont insisté pour que je
la laisse continuer ses études à l'école
elle à la haine ou non convaincu qu'il
n'y avait pas de différence
j'ai écouté leurs conseils et j'ai
laissé ma fille continuer ses études
[Musique]
cogan l'anem et vous de la priorité
actuelle ce sont les études pas le
mariage elle va se marier un jour mais
la priorité pour le moment ce sont ses
études
beaucoup de prétendants sont venus me
voir mais je leur ai dit qu'elle était à
l'école monsieur est venu en moto2
télimélé pour demander la main de ribes
et là j'ai dit non vous savez si l
épouser quelqu'un elle devra arrêter ses
études
le mariage précoce des jeunes filles
une pratique très courante ici un
obstacle majeur à l'éducation
[Musique]
tôt ce matin kadiatou diallo de l'unicef
est invité au baptême d'un petit garçon
au coeur du village de pape et le papa à
une trentaine d'années la maman elle
vient d'en avoir 14
le couple s'est marié il ya tout juste
neuf mois et leur bébé est né il ya une
semaine
[Musique]
il
il est gourmand ce petit bungalow tu as
souffert combien de temps avant
l'accouchement
environ six jours bon c'est mauvais ces
six jours
à ce moment on dit que tu as beaucoup
souffert il paraît que tu partes est aux
réfugiés en brousse
oui j'avais trop mal les gens venaient
me regarder et j'avais honte
c'est pour ça que tu aller en brousse
cités soeurs qui sont à l'école étaient
obligés de se marier à 12 ans quelle
serait ta réaction
je dirai à mes parents de les laisser
étudié comme moi je n'ai pas eu cette
chance
mais il faut que ça change mais pourquoi
elle est utile mais pas moi je suis un
héros
quand on me parle en français je ne peux
pas répondre c'est la honte à
l'extérieur dans la cour les hommes
procède au baptême à l'homme à cet
enfant a la bénédiction d'allah elle
s'appelle pardon il s'appelle anthony
philippe qui s'appelle anthony fils il
est chaud familles sont tombés d'accord
pour donner à ce bébé le prénom de
l'autre hôte de canal+
anthony philippe nous ment bon karma
n'est ni le bébé porte son nom parce que
dieu bénisse le bébé
[Musique]
kadiatou et de culture paul la même
ethnie que les gens d'ici
ça facilite le dialogue pour essayer
doucement de convaincre et changer les
mentalités
j'aimerais qu'on aborde le sujet de vos
filles que vous donner en mariage mais
très souvent elles sont mariées sans
avoir atteint l'âge de la maturité elle
dit chaque maire souhaite que sa fille
trouve un mari mais personne ne veut
voir ta fille souffrir moi j'ai fini mes
études et je me suis mariée après j'ai
trois garçons et deux filles
donc cela montre bien que l'on peut
faire des études se marier et avoir des
enfants
par la grâce de dieu nous avons une
école fait tout pour y mettre vos
enfants attendent et l'âge de la
maturité avant de donner vos filles en
mariage
il n'y a que ça qui peut la réparer la
souffrance
[Musique]
nous avons entendu vous conseille vous
avez aidé à avoir une école et nous vous
remercions
croyez-moi nous tiendra compte de vos
conseils
[Musique]
qui va être soumise à tous sans
conditions beaucoup plus d'obligations
que de droit il faut
[Musique]
l'an dernier à kindia nous avions
découvert une ville submergée par ces
déchets des rivières encombré de
détritus provoquant inondations et
bédénik un trafic d'ordures non triés
revendus aux maraîchers des environs
pour servir d'engrais
un cocktail toxique idéal pour plus les
terres et mettre en danger la santé des
paysans
depuis deux mois tout juste c'est le
grand nettoyage à kindia au centre ville
une brigade d'éboueurs s'active avant
l'ouverture des boutiques autour du
marché ça n'a l'air de rien mais ici
c'est un grand changement
on a préféré soutenir le secteur privé
donc on a appuyé l'émergence et impôts
la restructuration d'ing
un groupement d'intérêt économique
c'est-à-dire une micro entreprise qui
s'occupe de la gestion des déchets sur
le marché et ian khama qui s'il a donc
ton leur a mis à disposition du matériel
des charrettes des ballets décors etc et
surtout donc des remorques et un
tracteur donc on a une remorque bleus
pour tous les déchets le tout-venant
quoi et une remarque verte pour
les matières biodégradables donc les
matières biodégradables sont envoyés au
niveau des maraîchers genou cas sont
vendus là bas et les matières non
compostables et thouvenot et envoyés à
la décharge à décharge municipale le tri
pour assainir enfin kindia objectif
inciter les habitants du quartier à
séparer leurs ordures à domicile avant
de venir les verser dans la bonne
remarque le tri sélectif en france ça
après une dizaine d'années donc ici
c'est pareil ça va pas se faire du jour
au lendemain donc ça va prendre un peu
de temps
les gens ici il ya un an c'était des
déchets qui a occupé toute la route
c'était vraiment une montagne de déchets
là depuis qu'on a commencé il ya plus
rien donc déjà ça c'est un premier
résultat qui est encourageant et le bon
le ge c'est une équipe très motivés ils
ont vraiment envie de travailler pour la
salubrité kenya donc
ils sont motivés donc on va continuer
quoi
[Applaudissements]
non aucune recule recule encore
remorques verte donc pour les déchets
biodégradables
avec le tracteur financé par kindia 2015
direction les parcelles agricoles l
extérieur de la ville
kindia c'est le potager de la région 60
% des fruits et légumes consommés à
conakry la capitale de la guinée m d'ici
et comme les engrais chimiques coûte
cher les paysans préfèrent acheter des
déchets pour fertiliser leurs cultures
avancez un peu avance
[Applaudissements]
ce qu'on passe tes bons rails
c'était comme ça ouais c'était bien si
tout ce qui arrivait de cette qualité on
va se faire hacher de beaux déchets bien
verts et organiques
c'est ce qui permet aux 24 éboueurs du
groupement de commencer à se rémunérer
ses bons merci bon
afin de mettre assez bien trier c'est
parfait pour nous et s'il ya du
plastique ça ne va pas amoureux mais à
la fin c'est ce que nous utilisons ce
qui fertilisent nowshera borie un moment
c'est ce qui nous permet d'avoir un bon
rendement
c'est grâce à ce qu'on pense que nos
fruits mûrissent les objectifs de kindia
2015 convertir les habitants de huit
quartiers de la ville au tri sélectif
étendre la collecte des déchets grâce à
l'achat de douze remorque
supplémentaires et pérenniser ainsi les
24 emplois d'éboueurs nouvellement créé
bien qu est ce que nous devons faire ce
matin laisse à l'examen d'un t1
nous devons commencer par quel métier
j'en ai d'action alors ce matin vous
allez être dans votre classe dans les
différentes salles travailler librement
écrivez ce que vous savez vous pouvez
travailler
vous devez faire travailler votre tête
c'est que vous avez appris pendant
l'année c'est ce qu'il faudra donner ce
matin travaillé comme si vous étiez avec
votre m personne ne doit y avoir c'est
lui qui copie c'est une fraude et il est
éliminé
il est éliminé dans quel rôle doit
copier
non personne ne doit copier c'est à dire
chacun pour soi et dieu pour déjà vous
vous alignez devant vos places et vous
attendez les surveillants qui vont vous
installer de façon officielle ce matin
les candidats au collège viennent de
toutes les localités de la région
pour beaucoup d'entre eux c'est le
premier séjour loin de la maison
sept épreuves réparties sur trois jours
d'examens et initiatique
[Musique]
uribe l'as bari est arrivé la veille de
ma b son village
trois heures de marche avec son maître
et ses camarades après son échec de
l'année dernière et là une nouvelle
occasion de changer son destin
elle a même appelé ainsi
[Musique]
allam a fait deux mois plus tard
uribe la prendre à son résultat à
l'examen elle est la première de ce
famille être admise au collège de
télimélé m bangoura lui n'a pas atteint
les 85 % qu'il s'était fixé
mais six élèves de la classe qui passent
sur les onze présenté c'est très
encourageant
d'ici 2015 le projet kindia verra la
construction de 18 écoles au total soit
54 classe tenus par des enseignants
diplômés est rémunéré objectif doubler
le taux de scolarisation et atteindre
80% pour assurer un même accès à
l'éducation aux filles et aux garçons
[Musique]
vous aussi vous pouvez participer au
projet kindia 2015 si vous donner ne
serait-ce que 15 euros au fonds de
dotation kindia plus c'est déductible
des impôts et canal + double la mise
vous financez ainsi la distribution de
cahiers de trousses et de crayons à 40
enfants ou bien 4 cuiseurs à bois
de quoi changer le quotidien d'une
trentaine de personnes ou encore des
tests de dépistage du sida pour une
cinquantaine d'habitants de kindia
[Musique]